malaysian airlines jet flying from
Amsterdam 298 passengers launcher used
to shoot down the air crashing military
unit deny deny deny even in the face of
extremely compelling me
[Music]
my daughter was 17 years old she was
nice and white and enjoying your life I
wished her very good holiday
I said take care of yourself and then
she said you don't have to tell me that
ten times dead she was gonna make a
beautiful trip to Malaysia on July 17th
2014
malaysian airlines flight mh17 flying
from Amsterdam to Kuala Lumpur was shot
down over Ukraine almost 300 passengers
were killed 196 were Dutch immediately I
saw there was only one plane flying from
Amsterdam to Kuala Lumpur and that was
their playing so then breathing stops
and the floor was gone
and there were 30 casualties that's the
next hour 60 and next 80 so about the
whole plane was at forest home
the Netherlands and Australia now call
on the Russian Federation to engage
seriously and accept his responsibility
in May 2008 een after a four-year
investigation a Dutch led inquiry
concluded that the plane was shot down
by a Russian missile the Netherlands
says it will now hold Russia accountable
but the Kremlin denies responsibility
and refuses to cooperate
the Russians deny everything that makes
it very difficult and then they hope the
world forgets and is not interested in
between the truth now we are very much
interested in the truth does it bring
back our families no it doesn't but it's
shows that the rest of the world doesn't
accept it in international law it is
very hard to get jurisdiction of an
international court and we don't really
know what the Netherlands will choose of
its options the hague is the global
capital of international justice and if
there's one country that truly believes
in international law it's the
netherlands behind me is the
International Court of Justice also
known as the World Court so you would
think that the Netherlands would seek
justice for the downing of mh17 and by
taking Russia to court but it's not that
simple the International Court of
Justice in a Peace Palace in The Hague
adjudicates disputes between states
however the International Court of
Justice only has jurisdiction over this
case if both parties consents so
obviously this is really hard
international law is made up of treaties
the challenge in bringing a case is to
find a violation of a treaty that both
states have agreed to and then find a
court that administers that treaty that
can be complicated
the Chicago Convention is the main
treaty that governs civil aviation this
article 3-bits
provides that states must refrain from
using force against civil aircraft so if
Russia was actually involved in
launching the missile that brought down
mh17 that may well have violated the
Chicago Convention which would allow a
dispute to be settled by the
International Court of Justice but that
really depends on the extent of the
involvement of Russian state agents in
bringing down mh17 the evidence against
Russia is overwhelming photos and video
gathered from social media track the
missiles exact route from an army base
in Russia to the border in Ukraine they
have definitive proof the airliner was
shot down by a Russian army missile
system that same Russian mobile missile
launcher in Ukraine had it yesterday for
the Russian border with two of its
launch tubes empty and then a day later
the vehicle disappeared back in Russia
and Russia's alternative theories have
been repeatedly exposed as fakes using
falsified radar data and forged records
are you saying this was not a Russian
missile this was not a Russian army
missile you're finished
the Dutch might find it easier to bring
the case to the European Court of Human
Rights in Strasbourg the European Court
of Human Rights actually looks a lot
stronger in terms of jurisdiction
because both Russia and the Netherlands
as well as Ukraine are members of the
Council of Europe article 2 of the
European Convention of Human Rights
provides for the rights to life and that
entails that Russia cannot be involved
in bringing down a civilian aircraft the
obligations of Russia on the dis
convention are not only more detailed
but also clearer and therefore may be
easier to uphold in a court of law
though a successful prosecution of
Russia in any course will not guarantee
action the court's decisions are binding
but if States refuse to act on them
there is very little in international
law that we can do about it we do not
have an international army or police
force they can then enter Russia in
order to make them pay
[Music]
that's holding Russia as a country to
account but what about prosecuting the
individuals who fired the missile that
would be a criminal matter and the
International Criminal Court is also
here in the hague it does have
jurisdiction because ukraine invited it
onto its territory and it prosecutes
individuals but only when the countries
involved are unwilling to and the dutch
say they want to take this case with
mh17 it is very likely that individuals
will not be extradited by russia of big
benefits in the Dutch system is that it
allows for in absentia prosecutions
which means that under certain criteria
it's possible to prosecute people even
if they are not in custody but the
Netherlands would have to prove exactly
which officers were there and who did
what and the Russians are not telling
[Music]
last year we decided to place this bench
here with some relatives of family 17
victims you can sit here all day waiting
opposite the Russian embassy to get some
answers the best was taken from me my
only child Elswick who meant so much for
me and our families who perished can't
talk anymore but we can talk for them we
keep on trying keep on fighting for some
justice
[Music]